CNBC has a list of what it says are the
10 worst states to live and work in they
say they caught they compile the list by
the Numbers quote unquote it's a
strictly objective determination based
on the data they say now just to skip
ahead to the twist ending the list of
the worst states to live in begins at
number 10 with Florida one of the most
prosperous states in the country it's
one of the highest rates of people
migrating to it and it ends with um as
the worst state of all number one on the
list is Texas again a prosperous state
where hundreds of thousand people move
to every year my own State Tennessee
also makes the list which is news to all
the new transplants to show up here
every single day so it seems like all of
the worst states are exactly the states
where the most people want to live